in this interview is a plenitude of
acronyms and names for example asap and
axelrod are mentioned profusely because
many people are new to this topic
there's a link in the description
outlining what each of the acronyms and
names refer to specifically use this as
a compendium or an index to not get
overwhelmed as this topic can indeed be
overwhelming even for the acquainted
today's guests are george knapp and
colin kelleher on the topic of ufos the
hitchhiker effect and the recent book
skinwalkers at the pentagon linked in
the description in fact anytime a book
an article a video is referenced in the
toe podcast i've most likely placed a
link to it in the description george
knapp is an investigative journalist a
news anchor a talk radio host who has so
many awards that i have to read them
verbatim and this still isn't an
exhaustive list he's been recognized
with the edward r murrow awards peabody
awards and dozens of pacific southwest
regional emmy awards colin kelleher is a
biochemist with more than 15 years of
research in cell and molecular biology
for the past eight years calm has been
using forensic science methodologies to
investigate scientific anomalies
associated with the phenomenon click on
the timestamp in the description if
you'd like to skip this intro my name is
kirchey mungle i'm a torontonian
filmmaker with a background in
mathematical physics dedicated to the
explication of the variegated terrain of
theories of everything from a
theoretical physics perspective but as
well as analyzing consciousness and
seeing its potential connection to
fundamental reality whatever that is
essentially this channel is dedicated to
exploring the under nature of reality
the constitutional laws that govern it
provided those laws exist at all and are
even noble to us if you enjoy witnessing
and engaging with others on the topics
of psychology consciousness physics etc
the channel's themes then do consider
going to the discord and the subreddit
which are linked in the description
there's also a link to the patreon that
is patreon.com
kirchimungal if you'd like to support
this podcast as the patrons and the
sponsors are the only reasons that i'm
able to have podcasts of this quality
and this depth given that i can do this
now full time thanks to both the patrons
and the sponsors support speaking of
sponsors there are two the first sponsor
is brilliant during the winter break i
decided to brush up on some of the
fundamentals of physics particularly
with regard to information theory as i'd
like to interview chiara marletto on
constructor theory which is heavily
based in information theory now
information theory is predicated on
entropy at least there's a fundamental
formula for entropy so i ended up taking
the brilliant course i challenged myself
to do one lesson per day and i took the
course's random variable distributions
and knowledge
uncertainty what i loved is that despite
knowing the formula for entropy which is
essentially hammered into you as an
undergraduate it seems like it comes
down from the sky arbitrarily and with
brilliance for the first time i was able
to see how the formula for entropy which
you're seeing right now is actually
extremely natural and it'd be strange to
define it in any other manner there are
plenty of courses and you can even learn
group theory which is what's being
referenced when you hear that the
standard model is predicated on u1 cross
su-2 cross su-3 those are league groups
continuous league groups visit
brilliant.org slash tow t-o-e to get 20
off an annual subscription and i
recommend that you don't stop before
four lessons i think you'll be greatly
surprised at the ease at which you can
now comprehend subjects you previously
had a difficult time grocking the second
sponsor is algo now algo is an
end-to-end supply chain optimization
software company with software that
helps business users optimize sales and
operations planning to avoid stock outs
reduce return and inventory write downs
while reducing inventory investment it's
a supply chain ai that drives smart roi
headed by amjad hussein who's been a
huge supporter of this podcast since
near its inception in fact amjad has his
own podcast on ai and consciousness and
business growth and if you'd like to
support the toe podcast then visit the
link in the description to see amjad's
podcast because subscribing to him or at
least visiting supports the toe podcast
indirectly thank you and enjoy i'm also
not feeling terribly well so if i am not
at my tip-top shape please forgive me
okay
it seems like we're live great great
great okay welcome column welcome george
thank you so much for being here
thank you
man okay this is such a pleasure i've
been looking forward to this and many
many many people have been looking
forward to this so we'll get straight to
the questions forget about intros i'll
edit in an intro later
george this one's directed to you why
don't you explain to the people who are
unacquainted what the hitchhiker effect
is
we don't exactly know and i think a
hitchhiker effect should probably be
plural not just a singular form of the
term because there are many effects
the bass team first noticed it in a
correlation of things that happened to
people who visited skinwalker ranch in
particular there were at least five
maybe six
intelligence officials who during the
awsap program uh overseen and funded by
the defense intelligence agency these
intelligence officials visited
skinwalker ranch
had an encounter with something unusual
and then took something home with it we
don't know exactly how it works we don't
know why it happens but it's happened
over and over again it not only happened
to those people during the awsap bass
period but it happened to people who had
visited the ranch uh during the nidz era
and and even before then where people
would go to this property encounter
unusual phenomena ufos whatever and then
they would go home and they were visited
at their home by orbs by craft by crypto
type beings poltergeist type activity
broke out in their homes in one
particular instance that we describe in
the book there were these very seasoned
intelligence officials
who as part of the bass asap program
went to the ranch to check it out for
themselves they're walking during the in
the middle homestead
at night it's cold and suddenly gets
much colder they hit a cold spot where
it goes the temperature drops
dramatically in a matter of seconds and
they were sort of on high alert in fact
these guys were on high alert the whole
time they were on the ranch because they
read and heard about it
and uh they encountered some sort of a
an intelligence that had a sort of a
menacing presence it sort of froze them
in their tracks they backed off and
later when they went home they had an
eruption of paranormal activity in their
homes it is and generally the way it
works is it spreads to their family
members
the family members wives children see
these things ahead of time the one
character in our book axelrod not his
real name
we had to change that at the direction
of the pentagon when we submitted the
manuscript he had this explosion of
activity in his home that was seen by
his wife she saw this
standing on two legs a wolf creature a
wolf standing in her yard
its paws
crossed like this
leaning on a tree staring back at her a
couple of days later she didn't tell
anybody about it a couple days later her
kids see it they scream this thing runs
off down the street they can see it's
it's running on two legs
it's kicking up leaves
uh and they didn't know what the hell to
think about it but there were other
things that happened in the home
beings uh shadowy figures seen in the
home things moving around on their own
their pet had been moved they found
their dog up on the roof one day all
kinds of trickster type activity and
then it spread from the kids to their
friends in the neighborhood
uh that has happened a bunch of times it
happened there was a female agent who we
did detail in the book
a very seasoned battle-hardened
professional
who encountered something with column
and he can tell you about it they
encountered some kind of a creature a
crypto creature that people have dubbed
the dino beaver again in the middle
homestead this woman when she goes back
home
it's an immediate explosion of what you
call poltergeist type activity not
saying it is poltergeist is just similar
to that kind of activity that's been
reported over the decades by poltergeist
researchers uh in her home
a wine bottle flies across the room one
from one side of the room smashes on the
wall on the other side there are beings
that she sees at the side of her bed
things moving around in her home it was
so dramatic that her roommate who was
her fiance moved out ended that
relationship this activity has continued
for years um colin will tell you it's
happened to pretty much all of us who've
spent a lot of time on the ranch
including me i've never seen anything on
skinwalker ranch
but my wife has experienced things at my
home column's wife has experienced
things in their home bob bigelow's wife
experienced things in their home some of
it is benign and interesting and some of
it is downright scary we don't know why
it happens
but column with this biology background
can explain better about sort of the
effect of how it spreads it's like a
virus you mentioned it's benign and
sometimes deleterious is any of it
positive
not that i know of uh maybe column has
heard about that i mean it's positive in
the sense oh wow i got to see something
really strange there
it's kind of kind of thrilling my wife
the first time something happened in our
home and i i tried to make this happen
for a long time before i knew about the
hitchhiker effect i would bring things
home from skinwalker ranch to my house
try to engage whatever it was bits of
rocks and scrap and things taken from
the homesteads little tiny bits and
pieces to try to get it going and
finally it happened and it wasn't
pleasant my wife saw these blue orbs uh
floating over our our uh our house at
night she called me to come up and see
him by the time i got there they were
gone and then there was an experience in
our bedroom where this uh this thing
came in i'm not gonna go into a lot of
detail on that but it was a very
frightening experience for her
unpleasant and she didn't want it to
happen again well um you know the
interesting thing about the uh
hitchhiker effect is that it is
very very reproducible you know george
george said that you know back in the
even in the 90s the knits people
were experiencing this effect
but in terms of reproducibility
um
we know that uh going into between the
net zero which ended really in 2003 and
the bass era the asap era which happened
really beginning in 2008-2009
multiple security officers were deployed
on the uh on the skidmarker ranch
property
a lot of those people we've personally
interviewed about a dozen of them and a
lot of those people have brought quote
unquote brought something home same kind
of thing um poltergeist activity in the
house sometimes they see orbs in the
house um and then getting into the osap
era where everything seemed to really
escalate and uh these
these uh five out of five 100 percent of
the military intelligence people who
were deployed at the request of the
defense intelligence agency onto
skinwalker ranch did as george said
bring something home with them um and
you know even after robert bigelow sold
a skinwalker ranch
we have a new era of brandon fugal the
proper property developer from utah
purchased the ranch he installed a team
on the property and lo and behold we
have another set of instances of the
hitchhiker effect
and remember the people who went on
skinwalker ranch in
2016 were very very skeptical and they
were saying this is all you know this is
not absolutely you know this is all
fantasy and then stuff started erupting
in their homes they brought something
home with them and multiple instances so
in terms of reproducibility
the hitchhiker effect has continuously
affected people
uh for that we know of for about 25
years
um it may be longer on skin marker range
and the second point i wanted to make
was that it is not only skinwalker ranch
it is not sort of
only happening on skinwalker ranch but a
lot of a ufo um activity
does seem to give rise to the skinwalker
or the uh the hitchhiker effect for
people who have never been on skinwalker
ranch and just interact with the the ufo
phenomenon they themselves in some cases
i'm not saying in all cases but in some
cases and mostly where we have the
luxury of being able to study these
people over many months or many years um
a lot of these people um
you know uh report
elements of the hitchhiker effect you
know it's kind of ironic but going all
the way back to 1947 kenneth arnold uh
when he saw those nine
objects in the sky over the cascade
mountains
uh on june june of 1947
it's interesting long after he died um
his daughter went on a radio show she
was
talking about writing a book about his
life but she started talking about
seeing orbs in the in the arnold home
they have so
uh experienced various poltergeist
effects uh even kenneth arnold himself
in his book um talks about uh you know
some really weird happenings that were
happening um after the uh june 24 1947
i'm not unambiguously tying what
happened to kenneth arnold to some form
of the hitchhiker effect but i'm saying
that this effect is not just a
skinwalker ranch
specific effect it happens on a much
broader scale
you've been researching in this area for
decades or at least plenty of plenty of
years what piece of evidence do you find
most striking most remarkable for
whatever reason so one could be because
it's incontrovertible evidence toward
the existence of x or y or it led to
some new research area
um i think one of the most remarkable
things that
we found during the asap program and and
again uh the all-star program uh was a
24-month program that started
in uh 2008 and ended in 2010
but you know for the first time we had a
large team we had about 50 people who
were employed full-time at osap and then
we had 22 million dollars allocated
through the defense intelligence agency
for a two-year period so
it's very rare in the ufo
field to have the luxury of resources
and being able to study people over long
periods of time after you know they've
encountered ufos so i guess one of the
most remarkable sort of
discoveries that we made during the asap
program was
the intense medical effects
that that
that some of these
ufo
a cases
cause in in in some people i'll give you
an example um
one of the one of the sentinel cases
that we actually investigated over
about a year actually and and it went
into almost a two-year investigation
was that this biotechnologist and his
daughter were driving towards bend
oregon in their in their vehicle on
their way home
and the daughter notices three small
ufos
uh bluish color that were darting around
in the field beside them
um once she noticed them they
immediately made a beeline for the
vehicle as they were driving and
one of them went right across the
windshield one of them went uh came into
the car
and and went right across uh both the in
their field of view went right across
the uh the windshield uh inside the
vehicle but the third one actually went
through the left shoulder of this
biotechnologist went through the upper
uh thoracic cavity and then emerged from
the right shoulder and then shot out
through the uh the window right in front
of the daughter i mean this was a
terrifying episode for the for the
daughter especially uh she was
witnessing all of this
but you know within um i would say 24 to
48 hours
uh this guy woke up the following day
with the let the left side of his face
was all sunburned
um his his ear had started swelling his
eye he was started
losing the sight in his left eye
um within a week or or a couple of weeks
he started losing his hair on the left
side of his head and you know luckily we
had on contract md phd
a couple of md phds
um really sort of as as people who could
get deep into medical investigations and
look at medical injuries so we deployed
one of these people uh you know on this
case and he followed he followed this
guy over many many months but it turned
out that
a few months after this this event had
happened
he came down with a rare form of ductile
carcinoma
that luckily was not metastatic so it
did not metastasize
and over a two year period went through
a lot of a lot of health
issues
but in terms of being able to document
all of that we were very very fortunate
that we had access to blood samples
taken
from this guy before the incident and
then there were multiple blood samples
taken
after the incident
so we were able to
piece together a medical forensic sort
of picture
of what had happened
before and uh and after this incident
and we could document you know
rises and falls of various immune immune
system parameters within this guy uh we
we we saw that there were dramatic
changes in neutrophil lymphocyte ratios
over time and you know this was for from
a an asap
ufo investigation point of view we think
this was one of the sentinel cases
because
we we had resources and we were able to
we had the luxury of following this guy
over a year and a half to two years uh
after the incident and as i said we had
blood samples taken before the incident
so we were actually able to
postulate about cause and effect and the
sort of the dramatic increase in adverse
health symptoms that this guy had had
suffered um we were able to say with
reasonable confidence that he suffered
pretty well all of those
after the uh close encounter with this
uh small blue orb um so that that's that
was the case and we had uh several other
cases that uh
bas asap encountered that sort of um you
know looked at the medical injury aspect
and that was one of the things that
really surprised me
during the mid the nitz era we did not
encounter too many of those cases um you
know we were all the time databasing
cases
from um you know we had about 1 800
separate ufo investigations under our
belt by the time the nids database uh
went on ice which was about 2003
but we never saw in in terms of boots in
the ground investigations of ufo effects
we never saw the sort of level of
medical injury uh that we saw sort of
you know up close and personal with a
few of these cases so i guess that's one
of the things that really surprised me
from the
series of investigations
did that person feel any burning
sensation or any sensation at all when
the orb went through him
well he he actually did feel a sort of
really weird sort of uncomfortable
um it wasn't painful or or
anything he he felt sort of um
discombobulated and sort of out of sorts
as this thing was traveling through his
body was almost like um alar it felt
like a very very large bubble that was
moving through his body he actually did
feel the movement but he didn't feel any
pain or he didn't feel any discomfort he
just felt uh i would say it was sort of
a version of mild vertigo
okay george when we first connected you
mentioned to me that there's plenty of
meat on the bone so to speak in the book
skinwalkers at the pentagon which the
link is in the description for those who
would like to check that out now what
are you referring to what specifically
are you referring to that you feel like
people in the media either on podcasts
etc haven't picked up on and why do you
think it's so important those pieces of
information this question also comes
from dan from that ufo podcast
yeah well there there are a lot of ways
i could answer that i'll give you sort
of some bullet points one is the
documenting the difference between asap
and atep we're all glad that atip that
story hit the new york times in december
2017
uh but there were multiple errors of
fact in that story that they sort of
conflated awesack with atep asap is the
program that got 22 million dollars asap
was authorized and overseen by the
defense intelligence agency it was not a
small operation as column said it had 50
full-time employees working around the
clock and then hundreds of
subcontractors it was huge as far as we
know we believe there are other ufo
programs but as far as we know it was
the largest such endeavor ever funded by
the us government bigger than project
blue book uh bigger than uh than the
eight than atep by
many magnitudes and um i don't think
people get how just how big it was atip
grew out of bossap not the other way
around there were two distinct efforts
and this was huge number two is the
database the database that was created
by these guys is enormous it's more than
two hundred thousand different ufo cases
it incorporates uh not only project blue
book and us government files but also
private files compiled by nids the files
of other governments including brazil
uh documents reports case files things
of that sort it was enormous i don't
think there's anything like it anywhere
else in the world and had ossap been
allowed to continue one of the plans was
as envisioned by jacques valet who
created this database or data warehouse
was to put ai on top of it as a way to
filter and collate uh different cases to
look for patterns if that had been
allowed to continue if ossap had been
allowed to continue we'd be way further
down the road in understanding what this
phenomena is as it is we don't
understand it at all we don't know where
it's from why it's here what its
interest is in us we don't know what the
answers to any of those big questions
but it is possible it it they could have
been achieved they haven't been allowed
to continue
also the specific cases um
tic tac is probably the most famous ufo
case in the world that was an awesome
project they launched that investigation
and although we've seen bits and pieces
of what asap was able to determine about
the tic-tac the bulk of that information
the analysis that was done with a
specific kind of software has never been
made public a column could probably
address that a lot better than i can but
let me finish this list and then there
are individual cases things that
happened at skinwalker ranch crypto
creatures the different kinds of craft
that were investigated seen and
investigated by asap at the ranch and
then other places around the country
there's a case in georgia that was
investigated that is a mind-boggling
there's a a men in black type instance
that happened in kentucky that column
can elaborate on there's a southern
california
incident in ventura county where an
entire family had these experiences over
a number of days saw alien beings got
them on camera in fact and um
it had a kind of a trick ending but
those kind of cases i don't think they
have have registered with the general
public or the ufo public at all
column do you want to add to that
um yeah i i think uh
exactly what uh what george put out is
is the case and
i guess you know we can be sort of
blamed in some way because
we sort of set out to write a fairly
uh a fairly dense book
in in in skin workers at the pentagon
and we decided from the get-go that we
we could have added a hundred pages of
filler if we had so chosen but we
decided against that and and so
i think the book is is pretty dense um
there's not a lot of fluff in there in
terms of sort of
um
you know going going beyond what what
the facts were so um i think i think a
lot of people because of that and i
don't blame them personally but a lot of
people have missed some of the things
that are uh that are in the book and and
uh i think it does probably demand uh
more than one reading uh and you know a
lot of people i've noticed on social
media and and etc have focused and sort
of said that the asap program
was only focused on skinwalker ranch and
it was only focused on
exploring ghosts and what have we
but the fact is you know we submitted
104 separate reports to the defense
intelligence agency as separate
deliverables
during the asap program and only a
minority of those uh those reports were
focused on skin marker ranch the
remainder of the reports focused on you
know we we we did a um a pretty
extensive
um engineering analysis of the tic tac
incident and we compiled a report based
on
ansys
multiphysics analysis of the of the tic
tac case
computational fluid dynamics analysis
that was a 140 plus page report that was
submitted to the defense intelligence
agency that was completely separate from
the report that axelrod submitted on his
investigation and his investigation of
the tic tac effect so uh we also had a
lot of um
investigations of
um things like uh the russian uh ufo
papers that george knapp brought back
from uh from russia that was completely
independent of skinwalker ranch and uh
we we employed three separate russian
translators we got a lot of the uh
the documentation we got all of the
documentation translated we had analysts
take a look at it and we i mean we were
it was a mind-boggling array of an
organizational chart in uh russia's
slash soviet union in the early 1990s
which showed that the the soviet union
had this massive uh program that was
focused on gathering ufo uh data
nationwide at a national level uh
government departments were were
involved as well as university
departments uh involved
there was also this military unit called
73790 that was involved and it seemed to
be the sort of the linchpin of the
entire investigation and you know
they're being whispers about unit
73790 as being sort of fundamental to
the soviet union and later the russian
focus on the uap
agenda but you know senator reid when he
when he uh was instrumental in forming
this program
one of the
really sort of alarming things in his
mind was the prospect that another
country would be gaining traction on the
united states and you know he had in
mind russia and china
but other countries also that they were
gaining a technological edge because
they were actually taking the ufo topic
a lot more seriously um in in these
countries than they were in the united
states uh you know we have publicly we
know
we had project sign we had project
grudge we had project blue book and then
sort of laterally we had this very large
awesome program which unfortunately was
prematurely truncated after two years
just as it was really sort of getting
going and then we had this very small
effort in the pentagon called atip you
know uh so so in terms of
the publicly available knowledge of how
seriously the united states government
was taking the ufo phenomenon
the the thread three documents that asap
translated and analyzed shows pretty
unequivocally that the soviet union
slash russia had a much more serious and
and wider scope program
okay let's talk about the hitchhiker
effect for a little while this question
comes from
arthur arthur swatalsky and if i'm
mispronouncing that well forgive me
i believe this comes from twitter and
so i'm gonna paraphrase this it seems
like the hitchhiker effect is akin to an
a contagion
and the way that i understand it is that
it must be that it decreases with
severity the more that it's spread from
person to person otherwise we'd all have
it because we're connected so firstly
does it decrease have you found any
evidence that it decreases when it
spreads from person to person well i
would say sort of the poster child for
the uh the hitchhiker effect in terms of
our ability to study it over over time i
think your listener that's a very good
question actually because um it does
have a lot of implications
um but the poster poster child for this
was the axelrod family so axelrod was
the sort of the primary
primary infectee on on the onskin walker
ranch he flew 2 000 miles back to his
home in uh in virginia um within a few
weeks
both his sons and his wife had
experienced these dramatic effects that
george has alluded to
um
at the same time
neighbors started reporting
this was like a few months later
neighbors started reporting eruptions of
unusual effects
as school kids that the axle rods
knew
the axelrod kids knew uh also started
reporting weird creatures outside their
bedrooms and remember axelrod the
axelrod family
uh the you know the guy in the axelrod
family had top secret security
clearances um you know was a very high
level navy
um
person so
um the family were well used to keeping
secrets they were not sort of con sort
of the kind of kids that went to school
and blabbed about what their you know
their family was doing so they kept very
quiet about this whole thing so bottom
line is that there was a spread out out
into the neighbors
and out
out into the school kids
the the real question is how far this
actually spread and and we do not have a
full grasp on exactly how far it spread
but
i think the questioner is is really
correct because
we probably would have picked up
additional cases
if the
if this had spread you know into large
areas around the neighbor the
neighborhood uh as as confront you know
as opposed to what we actually did pick
up
in other cases we know that it's spread
through
through kids and in some cases
co-workers um
also uh were subject to this but we do
not have i would say the n is too small
um and again this comes back to the fact
that the asap program was prematurely
truncated
and you know the original plan was to
have a five-year program
we believe if ossop had been allowed to
continue for the full five years with
you know 50-plus full-time employees we
would have made a lot of inroads into
answering the kind of questions about
how far the hitchhiker effect
extends
you know because
my one of my backgrounds is
virology
um
and sort of it's it's pretty obvious
from the coronavirus up the update
everybody is familiar with the r0
concept and the ability of a virus to uh
to in fact new hosts so um i that the
the epidemiological analysis
of the hitchhiker effect is crying out
to be done
um if there was a follow-up program uh
for the uh of for awesome that could
document additional cases of the
hitchhiker effect right now we have
probably between two and three dozen
cases um of of the hitchhiker effect
over the last 20 to 25 years but you
know we need an awful lot more than that
and start in in terms of um documenting
uh the extent of this effect
but you know the tools of
epidemiological analysis
and modeling are are sort of they're
widespread every other lab
that studies coronavirus has you know
epidemiological modeling
you know
resources at their disposal so this
would be a very easy project to uh
extend all we need is additional cases
george do you have any comments on that
no i just i agree that it was a great
question i haven't really considered it
i know that for us my wife and i we
don't think it to spread any further
than that of course we
we have had no reports from people that
we know we don't have children and we
act we last couple years we've lived
like hermit so i guess that could
explain part of it but that's a great
question is how far it can spread we
don't know the answer to it
see what i'm wondering is what are some
of the other factors so it seems
proximity spatial proximity is a factor
maybe temporal in oh sorry maybe
temporal length so how long am i
spending with someone what are some of
the other factors
well you know one of the um
one of the sort of questions that i've
heard asked is
you know this could be just a
series of fantasies that happen in these
people's minds etc but you know there
are indications that for example in the
axelrod family that this creature that
uh that the wife saw independently from
the two kids in their home um left
physical tracks so for example you know
uh there were claw marks on the tree uh
when the axelrod family went out to
investigate after the second incident
with the kids uh they found all these
really obvious claw marks on the tree
right on the exact tree that this the
wife had seen this creature uh leaning
against that's number one they also saw
this creature throwing up a lot of
leaves in the in the backyard as it was
running um one of the axelrod kids got
besieged by orbs one night
in 2011 and uh woke up with physical
marks on his body or a lot of red wet
welts on his body
looked like you know frankly it looked
like he had been beaten up um after a
night
in which there was a lot of this
quote-unquote
paranormal activity in his house and in
his bedroom but he had physical marks on
his body um and they they actually
brought him to the er just to check him
out and and make sure that he was at
home from school the following day um he
had like intense influenza-like symptoms
after that too but um you know so this
is not only a
um
you know a sort of a a mind phenomenon
it does have physical effects on the
environment so you know it could be both
but um you know i wanted to emphasize
that there are physical effects um in
the environment as well
and just to add to just a reminder the
health consequences for people who come
into contact with these phenomena not
just at the ranch i mean you can look at
the highly publicized cases uh where
navy pilots have encountered ufos
without being too specific or giving
away personal information you can bet
that there's a chance that some of those
have had these experiences as well when
they go home it's not just poltergeist
type activity there are severe health
consequences there are diseases perhaps
the your audience kurt will remember
recent comments by dr gary nolan where
he admits he's was contacted by cia to
look into some of these long-term health
consequences for people who encounter
ufos nothing to do with skinwalker ranch
but people who get too close for too
long to ufos have severe medical and
health consequences that last for a long
time we need to understand that you know
we need to understand how that works uh
it's not just a weird stuff that they
see in their rooms at night it's
diseases and health consequences that
put their lives in danger kit green
wrote a paper about it
for awesapp for bass it's one of the 38
durds the reports that were
funded by bass to establish a sort of a
baseline for different aspects of what
asap was going to study
they contacted these different
professionals professors phds to look
into specific topics
that was
related to their own level of expertise
hypersonics for example
most of the people who wrote those
papers didn't know they're writing it as
part of a ufo study funded by dia uh but
they wrote it anyway projecting
what our state of the art knowledge of
in in a particular specialty is
projecting it out over
40 or 50 years
one of those papers one of those 38
dirds written by dr kick green
neuroscientist
was looking at the medical effects
that work
has inspired dr gary nolan and others to
take it a little bit further and look at
what are the health consequences of
coming into proximity uh contact with
the ufo
i should also let you know that the
audience for this is so variegated it
runs the gamut from people who are
extremely familiar with the ufo space to
people who are more interested in the
bread and butter of this channel
theoretical physics math consciousness
so
often there are these acronyms and they
may be unfamiliar to many people so
please if you have an acronym just a one
sentence explanation like what is
awesome dia et cetera when they come up
i know it's tedious but there's many
questions about that
no that's great that's a good idea
because we get it does get confusing for
people uh dia is defense intelligence
agency it's the pentagon's version of
the cia awsap is the advanced aerospace
weapons systems application program that
was the acronym given to the bass study
uh i'll get to bass in a second by the
dia bass is the bigelow advanced
aerospace space systems it's an offshoot
of bigelow aerospace it was the
contractor that got the contract from
dia for assat if you've got all those
acronyms straight and then atip which is
the advanced aerospace weapon no
advanced aerospace threat identification
program
is sort of the successor to asap it grew
up out of the the ruins of asap so to
speak that's the program that was uh
directed by lou elizondo
okay
calm your
column
do you look like you're
chomping at the bit
no no i i was uh actually um
removing something that came up on the
screen all right okay so this question
comes from kf and by the way if there's
someone in the audience who wants to
work on a legend or a compendium about
these acronyms so that it can be
so that someone can easily reference
them then please contact me okay so kf
has a question a very serious question
kurt have they considered testing the
hitchhiker's syndrome with people who
are blind or have been blind from birth
and are there different outcomes to this
that's for confidence it's actually
extremely mean to test it on someone but
yeah you understand the spirit of the
question yeah yeah i mean
you would have to sort of uh sign a lot
of waivers
um you know and and and uh you know you
would have a lot of examination
from the hipaa
that's another acronym but health
insurance portability
uh whatever it is act
in other words medical medical
confidentiality
um you would also have to make sure that
you had institutional review board
uh you know
check that box too before you got into
that kind of research because this is
human
uh human based research which is
extremely uh
tightly controlled by the national
institutes of health so once you checked
all those boxes
um and provided you know all of the
releases had been signed
it is theoretically possible to have
people uh who are blind you know
all the way across the uh the spectrum
um there's a there's a whole series of
studies
um that were conducted
by a psychiatrist called kenneth ring
he and and he studied actually
these anomalous
experiences and blind people
and found that the
anomalous experiences included
um consciousness related experiences
like near-death experiences
and uh found that the uh blind
individuals
uh were
absolutely equally
um capable of seeing near-death
experiences as they were as as you know
people with with normal sight now that's
that's quite a leap between what we're
discussing and near-death experiences
but i'm saying that there is precedent
for that kind of an analysis
but it does go back to the question of
how big is the n
and uh the n is pretty small with the
data that we have in hand
really what we want to see i think
george and i and jim lukaszki is
um
a another program that is focused
in the same way that utilizes the ossop
template
to study the ufo problem
and not just confine it to
small sort of
rifle shot type studies that focus only
on military pilots
once you start looking at
effects
of these
ufo encounters on people
then you start getting into things like
the hitchhiker effect and we think that
there is enough rumor and innuendo
regarding some of the military pilots
that have encountered uh these these
ufos to warrant studies that are
long-term on human effects as well
including psychological effects but also
medical effects um and especially over
long term um you know the
the old days of ufo investigations
occurring on people's own time during
the weekends you know which is sort of
the classic model of ufo studies uh that
the sort of weekend warrior model um
that really does not apply in this case
you've got to have the resources to be
able to study these people long term and
i'm talking months or years in some
cases in order to fully delineate these
kinds of effects i mean if you go out on
a weekend and you interview somebody for
three or four hours you record that
interview and you go home
the chances are you will pick up only a
very small percent of that person's ufo
experience you'll you'll pick up data on
ufo parameters
performance parameters uh how close it
was how how fast it did right angle
turns uh what kind of lights it might
have had and you can try to sort of
marry that to theoretical physics
concepts but really what you need to do
is to do that but also to look at the
long-term effects uh on humans because
without
you know both sides of that equation i
think you're looking at a very distorted
data set
okay speaking of physics this question
comes from mossy moose
during the asap program and potentially
continuing into the present day what
sorts of energy signatures pass through
the experiencers of uaps and the
phenomenon in close proximity and is it
related to neutrinos does this type of
detectable and measurable energy
signature play a role in the hitchhiker
effect
that's a pretty good question
i'm not a scientist i don't pretend to
be a scientist column uh that maybe is a
better question for him but i don't know
if they ever got were able to get that
specific so
well the the only
um the only
i guess
uh medical effects that we were able to
document um
in involved um
we think some form of potentially
non-ionizing radiation um
you know sort of we we um you know there
was another case that george uh briefly
mentioned and that was
um and this pertains to what i'm talking
about uh in in in georgia you know this
guy
um this guy was alerted by his dog
barking outside and this is a case that
we investigated you know pretty over a
long period of time but um he went
outside his his young boy and a couple
of neighbors were in a tent in their
backyard they were kind of in a
sleepover he went out to check on them
and check on the dog and right over his
property or hovering silently was this
massive black triangle
this large black triangle now it was
night time so he couldn't get a good fix
but he figured it was very very low um
he said it was massive the size of a
football field
so it was right over his uh
his property so we tried taking cell
phone photos um and you know all that
came out was just blackness because he
could see it silhouetted against the sky
but the resolution of his iphone camera
uh was was insufficient to pick it up so
he went back inside and and pulled out
um he had a very powerful flashlight so
we went back outside this thing was
still hovering above him
so he shone the flashlight up at it to
see if he could see any any features on
the underside of this this craft
and almost immediately
this a large intense blue ray
uh came from the the front side of the
triangle and shot right on him and he
immediately felt you know a lot of heat
and a lot he was kind of blinded and
felt a lot of heat he turned around and
crouched uh away from this but at that
stage he felt a lot of heat on his neck
and his back so he got you know he ran
inside because he you know he felt he
felt threatened but this blue light was
probably a foot in diameter and it
seemed to be
instantaneous
reaction to him shining the flashlight
at the underside of this object so
um
he looked at it from the window and uh
it took off at enormous speeds uh
heading heading you know up
in the sky and was gone very very
quickly
so he went to bed and sort of um
woke up with a very strong metallic
taste in his mouth
um he had a lot of sunburn on the back
of his neck um he had a headache uh he
did not feel well and sort of uh so
investigations start we were contacted
as part of the
uh the bass mufon mufon is the
acronym for mutual ufo
uh
yeah uh so so
uh we were we were contacted via mufon
about this case so we sent investigators
out we photograph this guy
he he started losing his hair on the
back of his head
and we had one of our physician
scientists go out and visit him and he
organized a set of medical visits to the
local clinic that documented him over
time he had a lot of health effects um
he had intense nausea over uh over this
whole case
and um so
you know there was indirect evidence not
direct evidence but from the
constellation of medical symptoms
including sort of strong metallic taste
in his mouth losing hair
intense sunburn on his skin uh and and
some other features
yeah one of the hypotheses that we came
up with for this case and for other
cases was uh non-ionizing uh radiation
um but we were never able to get more
specific than that it was some form of
electromagnetic radiation and we did not
we were not able to pinpoint the
intensity or we were not able to
pinpoint exact uh wavelength but we uh
there was a hypothesis put forward that
needs to be validated over time in
future cases that non-ionizing radiation
um you know was was used on this guy
there was a whole plethora of other
strange effects that this guy went
through um he had all these bizarre
electronic interference
uh phenomena that were erupted in his
home um he had as i said a lot of
medical effects
a lot of these um tumor tumors started
growing in his body luckily they turned
out to be benign and he was diagnosed
with castleman's disease and uh
eventually after a couple couple or a
few years he got better and uh you know
pulled out of it but you know there were
he was besieged by low-flying black
helicopters
um you know at one stage which is
another sort of feature
that that is associated with the ufo
phenomenon but why is it featured
associated with the ufo phenomenon
we don't have the answer to that but you
know one of the things that the lessons
learned from awesome is
that we think the template is robust
the template should be repeated
and it should be extended beyond the
two-year program so you know
the bottom line for for the future we
think for ufo studies is to do a five
plus year study
with the kinds of resources that asap
had and the kinds of um
personnel
that were devoted exclusively to
investigating the ufo mystery because
you know as everybody knows as a lot of
your listeners know
we've been looking at this um you know
in the public eye for 75 years that's an
awful long time to be uh wondering what
is this phenomenon
you know
one of the things that the osap program
was tasked to do
was to
delineate whether or not this phenomenon
was a threat to the united states and a
threat to national security
bottom line is
you know there are two aspects of of of
threat analysis
one is capability and the other the
other is intent
so
part a was capability and we
are our data warehouse and databases
were full of instances where we were
able to map out the capabilities of the
ufo phenomenon but in terms of intent is
a really big question mark after 75
years of looking at this ufo phenomenon
we still have no idea regarding uh
whether or not what the intent or what
the agenda of this phenomenon is so
therefore
our final report to the defense
intelligence agency we did not say that
the ufo phenomenon was a threat to
national security we said it was a
threat to human health
and that's a very very different you
know parsing of that sort of concept
it's a very very different thing to say
it's a bad thing for you for people to
be close to ufos but we were not able to
to gather enough data to determine
whether or not this was a threat to
national security
i i'd like to add kurt if there's one
underlying message from our book one
lesson learned uh from the awsap program
it's that you need to follow the
evidence where it leads the defense
intelligence agency crafted this program
as a ufo study that was its primary
focus is on ufos the technology whose is
it is it a threat can we duplicate it
can we figure it out and duplicate it
but it also had and everyone at dia and
within bass understood
that it also was going to follow the
evidence wherever it lit since our book
came out and some of the the details
about ossap and bass we've had a lot of
criticism oh gosh that was a silly
program it was they were ghost hunters
they were looking at bigfoot all these
goofy silly topics paranormal stuff
that's been discredited well that was
not entirely true
it was a ufo program to start but they
followed the evidence where it led and
it led into some pretty strange areas
they didn't set out and didn't want to
study ghosts or poltergeists and we
don't even know if that's what they were
studying but they did study the effects
that were in proximity to ufo events
followed the evidence where it led and
it led into some very uncomfortable
areas the pentagon of course has has
been a little less than honest with the
public about its interest in ufos but
finally as a result of the atep story
that was in the new york times and uh
testimony from a lot of the people that
worked with column at ossap
behind closed doors congress is finally
interested in the ufo aspect and more
power to them we're glad that they took
the trouble to find out about the
national security implications uh of
these ufo encounters over military bases
if that is the engine that drove the
interest in a creating a new program
which they have done great but you can't
just stop there again the underlying
message of awesap bass the book that we
wrote is you have to follow the evidence
where it leads you cannot solve this
mystery or these multiple mysteries by
just looking at military cases at ufos
that appear over military bases at ufos
that are picked up on sensors or on
thermal images like tic tac like gimbal
you're never going to solve the big
picture by only looking at that stuff
you have to follow the evidence where it
leads and that takes courage and it
takes some money too
so
when i was speaking to travis walton he
was of the opinion that some of these
beings are benevolent and that they
would cure cancer potentially someone
else thought this as well i believe her
name is anjali she believes that they're
kind bestowing generous helpful it
doesn't sound like you all believe that
but
but
please comment on that
well we we don't even know if that's one
intelligence or multiple maybe there's
more than one more than one answer maybe
they're extraterrestrial
uh maybe they're interdimensional maybe
they're time travelers maybe there's
something else more exotic crypto
terrestrials ultra-terrestrials we
really don't know and we don't know that
it's just one it could be many different
ones with different kinds of agendas
yeah there are indications
call them alien editorials people who
are contactees abductees over the years
who say they've been given messages by
these beings we want you to take care of
your planet we want you to be kind to
each other quit blowing up atomic bombs
pay attention to the environment you're
polluting your planet they express an
interest in human development and human
health and there are rare instances
where they've supposedly helped humans
overcome crippling diseases but overall
you know there are a lot of contrary uh
indications as well sometimes these
intelligences seem to be just completely
oblivious to us uh they don't care
whether we see them or not they they
don't seem to want to interact with us
sometimes they lie to us uh jim semavann
of cia i interviewed him a couple of
days ago he says you know looking at the
databases and they then the vast uh uh
over arching uh information about the
subject is that
we don't know what they're here for or
what their interest is in us they lie to
us they trick us they mislead us they
take on different shapes we don't know
where they're from we don't know how
long they've been here i mean we don't
know any of the answers to the really
big questions so i am reluctant to
assign um a motive to to any of them of
these different intelligences we don't
even know how many of them there are
i would agree with that i i i think the
um
the vast majority of the cases that we
looked at um through the
uh asap database seemed to indicate that
um people were having physiological
effects and medical effects but there
were a subset of cases that do directly
address your listeners question and and
you know there was a sense of uplift uh
you know feeling feeling that at the end
of the day
that this was a positive effect on on
you know they they had a life-changing
experience as a result of interaction
with ufos um but in general was a
positive effect and you know as george
mentioned there were sort of there are
sporadic cases
of of uh these uh where where people are
healed quote unquote from various
ailments as a result uh these are
anecdotal uh you know everything to do
with ufos is anecdotal unfortunately but
you know
in our database i think that the vast
majority of the cases uh were not this
benign subset but there was a benign
subset um
associated with uh positive effects i
mean even going back to
uh skinwalker ranch
just after the sherman family
had sold the property to robert bigelow
in 1996
the last thing that they saw
as as the husband and wife were on the
property was they lucked up and it was a
bright sunny day and this disc this
silver disc came right down
um and and harvard you know it was in
the sky
and they felt enormous positive
uh feelings and sort of you know
after the nightmare that just gone
through over a two-year period this was
sort of the parting shot from a silver
disc which was a classic uh ufo uh in
the sky
and their overwhelming take-home message
from that encounter was very positive
you know very joyful etc etc
we have no idea why that happened um or
it was this was this just a random
occurrence uh but it was a very a
positive experience uh in their book
speaking of books there are plenty of
questions
which reference the book in fact this
guy arthur who asked a question earlier
arthur swatalsky he's such a trooper he
just outlined page number and then a
question on that page number so on page
49 he says in regard to lou lu
elizondo's remote viewing talents has
lou or anyone else on the team of bass
used their remote viewing capabilities
to
see into installations of that
purportedly house craft slash bodies or
to communicate with slash locate uaps
and then they even wrote in bracket this
ties into page 120 on remote viewing
they have
spent so much time
annotating the pages because frankly i
don't know what page 120 says but um
in terms of remote viewing um
bigelow aerospace advanced space studies
uh proposed a remote viewing project to
defense intelligence agency as part of
the menu or proposals that we submitted
in response to the request for proposals
that dia put out
dia actually rejected that proposal uh
they said we don't want to spend
enormous amounts of money train training
remote viewers but they did allow us to
conduct a pilot program
on the uh on remote viewing and in the
book
at um we we did a contract with
uh legendary remote viewer joe mike
monagle who um we you know
per the usual method for remote viewing
we gave him only
latitude and long longitude coordinates
and um
he produced a report for
the defense intelligence agency
ultimately but bass and
in it he mapped out the property and he
talked about various beings on the
property um
in terms of a full-fledged um remote
viewing exercise
we were not permitted under the
contract that we were given to
do a full remote viewing of the uh you
know during the bas program so we were
not permitted to do that by the defense
intelligence agency
george you have anything to add to that
yeah i'd add this is that
column and i wrote an earlier book
called hunt for the skinwalker which was
mainly focused on nids which is the
national institute for discovery science
pardon all the acronyms but nids was an
organization created by mr bigelow prior
to him getting a contract for the dia to
run this other program and needs studied
among other things skinwalker ranch in
in utah and just as sort of an
experiment as a side note while
preparing that book i had tasked a
remote viewing group here in nevada to
take a look at the ranch without telling
them what i was asking them to look at
they found some interesting things they
found evidence of military surveillance
they found some indications of
underground facilities and control rooms
so they were able to pierce the veil of
of a sort but of course i was never able
to physically verify what they saw in
these reviewing visions was actually
physically there yeah it would be a
really interesting task and an endeavor
to try to get remote viewers to take a
look at not just the ranch but other
places like area 51 or places where we
suspect
recovered disks for medical medic metal
pieces bits and pieces from crash sites
might be stashed we haven't done it
okay this question comes from da gummit
i'm late to the party but i finally read
the book sobering is right two questions
number one do other countries have the
same after effects specifically the
archetypal beasts as north america
because it seems culturally specific
and then well let's tackle that one
first
well for example bigfoot if you talk
about crypto creatures has been seen
everywhere in the world i think maybe
hawaii might be the only place where
something like it hasn't been seen and i
could be wrong there um so a lot of the
crypto type creatures that we see here
uh dog men wolf men um you know uh
creatures that are wear creatures
they've been seen all over the world in
every culture so there are a lot of
similarities i think there are specific
kinds of crypto creatures that are
unique to different parts of the world
um we've seen at skinwalker we've seen a
mix of them
i mean it almost gets bizarre and
ridiculous there are creatures that have
been seen there by the ranchers and
property owners neighbors that don't
exist in nature column salt one of them
column experienced that walking with the
female intelligence officer in the
middle homestead at the ranch and they
saw what uh what uh people have
laughingly called a dino beaver uh
column maybe you want to tell that story
what this thing looked like yeah i was i
was on the property uh with robert
bigelow and uh with um the person
in the book who was uh a defense and
intelligence analyst her name was juliet
with
and um you know
um during the day um
juliette and and i had walked the
property we had done a lot of
photography of the property i had
briefed julia on the various um
incidents that had happened during the
national institute for discovery science
program on the ranch uh julia climbed up
on top of the skidwalker ridge which is
the northern prop
property or the northern part of the of
the ranch and she took a lot of
photographs
so that night at about 10 o'clock
myself robert bigelow and juliet went
down to an area near homestead number
two which is kind of the center of the
ranch but also the location where
over the last 25 years there have been
literally dozens of anomalies
reported and recorded
and uh and and witnessed so
uh what we did was um we had we had
chairs with us we sat out in the in the
middle of a pasture uh near homestead 2
about probably i don't know 50 feet away
from homestead 2.
and that the way the chairs were
oriented where uh we were back to back
to back so each one of us was facing in
a 60 60 degree angle away from each
other so we could essentially cover the
entire 360 degrees so
um we noticed myself and robert bigelow
noticed that
juliet was was really getting
you know she was getting pretty jumpy
because
you know it was pretty it was very very
dark uh it was you know you could see
the faint light of homesteads
um way in the distance and we were
sitting out sort of sitting ducks in her
mind uh and and i guess in our minds too
sitting ducks for anything that wanted
to sort of pass by so she was getting
pretty nervous so robert bigelow sort of
got up and walked down
he was strolling down
uh about a hundred yards south so i got
up to um
you know to head over to the opposite
direction in the direction of the uh
homestead 2 building which is an
abandoned homestead about 100 years old
that's kind of like in ruins
so
about 30 feet in front of me i see this
what looks like a
maybe somewhere between 100 to 150 pound
creature that's motoring along the tree
line in front of me up it's about 30
feet away i looked over at juliet wit
and she's looking at it too
and this thing looked like it had
um like blocked uh
blocks on the
spine emanating from the spine
i guess the nearest equivalent i can
think of in terms of what what i was
looking at is a very very small version
of a stegosaurus but i could see also
and this was very very dim light um this
creature was motoring north um and it
was absolutely silent it had what looked
like a flat tail uh low to the ground
and it was a pretty bulky creature i
mean it was small but it was pretty
bulky and my estimate you know in
hindsight is probably somewhere between
100 and 150 pounds but what the most
bizarre aspect of this whole thing was
that it was like a cone of silence had
descended on the uh you know on this
whole area and you know even the
crickets
you know this kind of ambient noise
out on the out on skinwalker ranch when
you're sitting there for hours
all of that has had stopped there was no
noise whatsoever and this thing was was
motoring north it should have been
rustling and you know leaves and grass
as it went by was maybe
i get i'm guessing about 30 maybe 40
feet away from me it was probably 50
feet away from juliet so we watched this
thing it made a beeline for the the
corner of the abandoned homestead 2 and
went behind it and it was like you know
probably a few seconds later myself and
juliet sort of went right over to try to
follow this thing to get a better view
of it and we couldn't see any side of it
we went around the corner of the of the
building turned right and there there's
a sort of a gap between the corner of
the building and as a set of trees that
eventually ends up on the
uh on the track that goes east west on
skinwalker ranch we could not see any
sign of this creature but you know it's
kind of like
the moment in time
uh was pretty short you know maybe
i don't know probably less than 30
seconds when we were looking at this
there was absolute silence and it was
like uh a sort of a version of shock
when you're seeing something like this
and then by the time it got behind the
building i mean
if we had
had the ultimate sort of planning move
into high gear instead of being in
involved with this oz effect
we could have got the night vision
binoculars out
we searched for the creature with night
vision binoculars but we couldn't find
anything but this is an example of
the kind of
thing that happens on skinwalker ranch
and yes it is very easy to sit on a
couch or sit on an armchair and say why
the hell didn't you guys you know take
your night vision binoculars out but you
had to be there um you know there are
plenty of instances on skinwalker ranch
when we have captured photographs we
have captured
videos of fast-moving orbs and this kind
of thing we have gobs of photographs of
of these orb-like structures on on skin
marker ranch but that time looking at
this creature you know i you know uh if
i had to do it all over again i would
have had the night vision binoculars a
lot more sort of prepared in my grasp
for people who want to see some of those
images that you recorded or videos where
did they go
um they're all in the uh the niz
repository which has never been released
is there a plan to release it
um that's uh i i don't own that uh that
data set that would have to be the owner
of the of the data set and that would be
uh robert bigelow and niz i mean this is
a private uh was a private company and
it was accumulating private
privately held data
for analysis now all of the data that
nid's acquired over time
um is still on the ned's website there's
a cached version of the nid's website we
wrote gobs and gobs of papers that we
published on the nids website all you
need to do is google national institute
for discovery science wikipedia and you
will find a full
uh cached version of the nid's website
there are dozens and dozens of papers on
the news website that the net scientists
actually published on that website so in
terms of our published data it's all
available you know just happens
photographs of orbs are not available
but there is a very large data set of
published literature
involving everything from investigations
of cattle mutilations
to
investigations of ufo phenomena and
they're all written up in the scientific
vernacular on the needs website and
actually i looked at this website
yesterday so it is
actually available as we speak so if
people want to look at the raw data as
published in these uh in these ned
studies they're all available in this
cached website
i should point out the awesome
information and database is mostly not
public either we've given in our book
we've given a glimpse of of what was
available
as colin mentioned earlier uh bass
produced 104 reports that were submitted
to dia many of them with photographs and
charts and all kinds of evidence
that information has not been made
public
we hope that someday it will be you know
in writing the book
uh we told as much as that story as we
were allowed to tell it took 14 months
for the pentagon to sign off on our
manuscript they went through the this
dobson process we did have to make some
changes that they mandated
specifically especially about names of
active duty personnel we told as much of
that story as we could but there's a
gigantic amount of information that was
sent to dia
that i know a lot of foia requests have
been filed
none of that has been made public yet
but we think it should all be made
public eventually
this question comes from jackson vega
ask them what they think of stephen
greer ce5 protocol
well um i think it's worth a try you
know i i had a chance to interview some
guys who uh
they they are sort of like the prophet
yahweh it's this guy who 20 years ago
said he could call in ufos and he'd go
out and meditate and try to draw things
in and uh and sometimes it worked and
sometimes it didn't uh there's a group
of fellows that i know who have tried
this picked up the mantle and have been
had some amazing experiences that
they've videotaped
um
summoners i think they call it summoning
so it it does happen it it can happen
stephen greer who did some really great
early work in getting ufo whistleblowers
to come forward getting their testimony
out to
national
media organizations is a champion of the
ce5 he charges a lot of money for people
to go out into the desert when him and
call in flying saucers uh a lot of
people are put off by how
expensive it gets and and where the
money goes especially since it looks
like people can do this on their own
without paying steven greer to do it i
you know i don't know if it really works
but what the heck i say it's worth
giving it a try
column do you have any thoughts on it
yeah i would agree i think uh i think
it's worth
you know attempting it um i know that
it's been attempted in multiple places
there's been large programs in south
america
associated with summoning
ufos and
from the reports that i've seen
mostly um not scientific reports but
books and uh and magazine articles that
there does seem to be a level of success
but i would inject a note of caution
into this is be careful what you
actually
uh summon and you know um it it
it could be that these
uh objects come in all shapes and sizes
and like we've said for the last uh
hours so we don't know what the agenda
of of these objects are i mean it could
be some some have a benign agenda and it
could be that some have uh not a benign
agenda so i would inject a note of
caution i personally
i would not do that because i have too
much much respect
uh and caution regarding this phenomena
uh because we know too little about this
phenomenon and uh it's a case of be
careful what you wish for
i feel exactly the same i've been told
kurt look into it and perform it i'm not
i'm not going to at least not anytime
soon because
it's playing with fire it's worse than
playing with fire when i was speaking to
tom delong he expressed similar
sentiments saying that you don't know
what you're dealing with and it's
it could be extremely extremely
dangerous so i'm of that same opinion
yeah i mean i i
i kind of liken it to i mean if you
summon anything without uh
without careful sort of training and all
of that
um you you really are opening yourselves
up i would say the same goes for
ayahuasca tourism for example and this
this whole idea of sort of going to
somebody's place that you don't know who
they are and taking a bunch of ayahuasca
or dmt or any of the hallucinogenics um
again it's be careful what you wish for
uh i mean the originator of this whole
dmt phenomenon rick strassmann um who
was actually you know he was fundamental
in sort of initiating the the focus on
dmt in the western world and he did a an
nih-sponsored study of injecting a whole
bunch of volunteers
under under medical medical supervision
uh in new mexico and uh there's an
enormous number of these uh young
volunteers
uh reported
encountering these creatures and unusual
uh you know unusual people in in these
other realms
but you know rick strassmann later on
decided to back away from that research
because he found that some of these
uh these young people were having
long-term psychological effects and
again you know
under under control conditions it's all
very well to do this but you know what
are the long-term effects uh what are
what are these entities that people are
actually needing and conversing with i
mean do you really get the secrets of
the universe or do you get something
that you may not have bargained for and
that you find very a lot of difficulty
in getting rid of and you know i mean
the list goes on and on teenagers
playing ouija boards and what have we
you've got to have a certain amount of
caution uh when you're approaching these
kinds of phenomena and um especially
when we know so little about what the
long-term effects are
this question comes from richard
brewster i just read skinwalkers at the
pentagon now with all these research
with all this research being unable to
come to a conclusion as to the origins
or intents of the phenomenon
does something lead you to speculate in
one extraterrestrial origin
direction versus the phenomenon being of
earth origin i'll just tell you i've
been as a as an investigative reporter
i've been chasing this since uh the late
80s i think the first ufo related
interview i did was 1987 and i jumped
into with both feet starting in 1989 and
the dominant paradigm at that time was
these are ets within ufo world within
the the community of ufo researchers
they generally thought these are
extraterrestrials or visitors from other
planets who've been coming here for a
long time if you look back at the
history of humanity of recorded history
these things have been reported in every
culture on every continent throughout
human history in one form another
they've been with us a long time maybe
been here longer than us but we still
don't really know what they are uh that
e.t uh paradigm that which is where i
started it changed over time you know
reading dr jacques ballet's uh books
i i think the first interview i had with
him in 1990 he said look
i'll tell you i'm going to be really
disappointed if it turns out that the
ultimate answer to the ufo mystery is
that it's merely
visitors from other planets because he
said the technology that we've seen has
been demonstrated and documented over
the years is they control space-time
somehow they can manipulate gravity and
time and space in ways that we don't
understand so they could be
extraterrestrial and interdimensional
and time travelers all at once they
could be something even more exotic that
we don't understand i think the e.t
explanation is one that is possible
but we really don't know i mean some of
these beings in their messages to
contact these they say they're from
other planets but again i would
emphasize you can't really trust them
because they lied to us over the years
so
et is one possibility
but it's only one and my suspicion and
it's it's much more exotic and more
complicated than that that whatever it
is has been here with us forever uh
maybe longer than us that it lives here
it's not from some other place then it
lives here and
that's just a guess we really don't know
and and i'm not going to be the person
to figure it out somebody's going to win
a nobel prize someday figuring this out
but it's obviously not going to be me
column
well i think you know
i think it's really a shame
that um for 75 years
a lot of really smart people have looked
at this phenomenon
and
you know there have been stops and
starts and and
small programs large programs but you
know ultimately
this requires sort of a level of funding
from the national science foundation
from the national institutes of health i
mean the national institutes of health
annual budget is 44 billion dollars or
43 billion dollars in thereabouts
even if a small subset of of that were
devoted to
effects long-term effects in terms of
psychological effects
sociological effects
physical effects
uh medical effects
of ufos i think that would be a window
into this phenomenon if the national
science
foundation were able to fund a say a
10-year program that was would focus on
you know getting to the heart of what
this uh ufo performance
all of the physics associated with uh
with ufos and come up with a theoretical
model
based on actual data
that is really where where i think this
whole thing should be going because we
are unfortunately in the situation where
we've had
small sort of programs that are trying
to do something um and then they get
truncated or aborted
and um you know there's a certain amount
of data that comes out
i think all we know at the end of the
day is that what looks like
some kind of intelligence
seems to be interacting with the human
race
now is that intelligence living on the
planet since before humans or is it
coming from another dimension or is it
coming from another planet um there
really is not enough data to to come
down on either side i mean we don't even
know
uh what sort of level of um
you know um
i i would guess agenda
um or
you know what what does what is going to
happen with this this phenomenon in the
future as it continues interacting with
with humans it seems like over the last
75 years there seemed to have been sort
of a set of different waves
associated with how this uh this
phenomenon has been interacting with
humans but again we're looking through
sort of very
sort of distorted viewpoints you know
i'll give you one example
uh during the asap program we
interviewed uh
colonel barry hennessey who was a legend
at air force office of special
investigations also known as afos ipj
and one of the things that he said was
yes of course the air force utilized the
uh the ufo phenomenon back in the 70s
and 80s uh to disguise you know some of
our really advanced technology programs
you know when when an advanced version
of a an aircraft crashed in in northern
new mexico in the uh in the 80s you know
we did a lot of sort of behind the scene
amplifying the idea that ufos were
involved in order to cover the tracks of
a a very advanced part of a special
access program had crashed in northern
new mexico so
we know also from interviewing colonel
hennessy that some of the so-called
northern tier intrusions of ufos into
the northern tier
air force bases the missile bases that
dot along the northern part of the
united states
near the canadian border some of those
were actually
ours they were they were intrusion
detection operations to see how
ready the uh the air force bases were in
terms of reacting to unknowns coming
over but colonel hennessey also told us
some of the intrusions that happened
were not ours
you know it was like we have no idea who
they were they were certainly not ours
but we don't know like who they were so
you have this sort of constant sort of
um
ambiguity regarding
who owns what's what's going on is it
ours are bris or is it theirs i mean
one of the one of the the analytical
sort of tools that we've used at uh at
the end of osap was we we used this sort
of idea that there was there's two
levels of deception
going on
you know with the with the ufo
phenomenon one is the level of deception
where the united states government and
military is deceiving the public in
terms of mimicking the ufo uh phenomenon
for their own purposes in terms of
operational security and then there's
the other side of the phenomenon where
the phenomenon appears to be mimicking
some of our special access programs for
example these
the eruption of the large black
triangles that happened
throughout the united states through
europe in many places in south america
all of these
huge triangles
um seem to be
very closely aligned what with a lot of
people would have imagined were special
access programs of the united states
military but at the same time you know
there were hundreds of cases that were
mapped and investigated by our our
organization national institute for
discovery science and osap
that documented these large black
triangles that were floating at very low
altitudes brightly lit
over populated areas or down interstate
highways now why would a special access
program that was sort of top of the line
technology by the united states military
being so foolhardy as to
um you know be flying over populated
areas fully lit
with bright lights um and sometimes
altitudes reported by eyewitnesses a
couple of hundred feet i mean that is a
gross violation of national security
parameters of special access programs
but yet there are hundreds and hundreds
of cases of these that were very very
well documented by both national
institute for discovery science and by
asap i mean the case that i talked about
in um
in uh
in georgia involving this very large
black triangle that was literally
floating over this guy's uh neighborhood
that happened in 2009 i mean it was you
know it was not sort of way back in
history it was relatively recent but we
have these
um during the sort of investigative
process
uh we have these two layers of deception
that we always have to look through in
order to get to the the data regarding
ufos and that's not like a normal aspect
of scientific
uh you know research or analysis
normally in the field of biology or in
the field of physics you are not looking
through data
or at data through a couple of layers of
deception i mean it makes a thing it
makes things very very difficult um of
applying the scientific method to these
kinds of uh problems
george anything to add to that
oh just uh sort of uh playing off of
what i i said to begin with as you know
uh as a journalist i've tried to get my
head around this and i've
investigated it
for more than 30 years and i don't have
the answers to it the best uh the best
evidence for me what got me interested
in the subject is the paper trail our
government has known for a long time
these things are real and i know the
scientific community the journalism
industry have both dismissed it they've
laughed at it they've disregarded it
they painted very little attention over
many decades but our government our
military specifically knows this is real
they've known it for a long time and you
can trace it
through this paper trail of documents
internal reports many of them written
before the freedom of information act
exist in which they admit to each other
candidly in documents that they never
thought would ever see the light of day
this is real it's not ours we don't
think it's russians it can do things we
can't do we need to figure this out and
ever since then there have been studies
of it i have followed that paper trail
and others have as well
there's a legitimate mystery here that
needs to be figured out it hasn't been
figured out it's been
dismissed and ridiculed and laughed at
and now because of some of the
information that's come forward and been
made public by the likes of dr colin
kelleher dr hal put off dr kit green dr
eric davis jacques ballet edgar mitchell
serious scientists serious professionals
who've had the courage to look at this
and then allowed me to be a fly on the
wall
there's a lot of progress that's been
made
hopefully that will continue but you
can't just ignore it and ridicule it um
your viewers
kurt the people who listen to your
program
big brain people like that
need to take a look at this it's a
legitimate mystery it really is going on
it may be central to human existence uh
it may be the biggest question we ever
tackle once we figure it out it will
change everything we're already
undergoing some changes because of the
revelations of the last four years and
it's a worthwhile endeavor
we need to fund it it needs to be
studied we need to figure this out
that's what i would add
you mentioned that there are black
helicopters that follow a ufo sighting
do you think these helicopters are part
of the phenomenon or do you think that
they're government related is the
government tracking picking up some
trace
what is the purpose if you were to
speculate off obviously when we're
talking about this topic all of it is
speculation anyway or most of it is
speculation
my guess is it's both it's both
the phenomena
that assumes different shapes these
things these craft the beings themselves
are shape shifters we have a lot of
anecdotal evidence over a long period of
time that they can change their shape
and i think some of them appear in the
sky as black helicopters at the site of
for example cattle mutilations which is
a whole other topic we can get into
and then there are government uh
operatives who are monitoring the
phenomena themselves who assume that
same thing who operate
and they know that it's going to be
dismissed to some weird conspiracy some
ufo-related sighting they can operate
with impunity knowing that there won't
be any real investigation by science or
the media because it's conspiracy stuff
you know it's wild wacky conspiracy
stories i think in many cases the black
helicopters are both some unknown
phenomena assuming that shape and our
government monitoring that phenomenon
column
yeah uh
back in the uh in the nids era
we we have we were very fortunate to
meet a guy called captain keith
wolverton
um who was stationed in cache county
just outside milestone air force base
in the uh in in the 70s and 80s and
you know mastermind air force base is
legendary in the ufo uh
annals
because there have been so many
incidents where
low-flying ufos have been documented
around milestone air force base
including during the late late 1960s of
of the actual missile launch parameters
being interfered with by ufos all of
that is well documented in books
um but
what really struck us in talking with uh
captain keith wolverton was that he
became
friendly with the base commander at
baltimore for space and so he the police
force around malston air force base
began a very close level of cooperation
between uh the police and the um and the
military people on the air force base so
anytime a ufo would show up um
captain keith wolverton knew about it
and so he was able to document over time
um there would be sometimes uh jet
aircraft launched from milestone air
force base to try to intercept these
ufos but one of the really weird
features that happened during this
wave of ufo activity was that side by
side
with this wave of ufo activity it was
also a wave of helicopters that neither
the air force based personnel or the
police force that were tasked with
investigating
co-investigating these cases um had had
any idea where they were coming from now
i'm not talking about one or two
signings of helicopters i'm talking
about somewhere between 50 and 100
separate sightings of these
quote-unquote black helicopters that
seem to show up in the aftermath of uh
ufos and layered on top of that
according to cat captain keith wolverton
was there was a a literal explosion of
unusual phenomena in people's homes and
around the area within a 10 20 mile
radius of malstrom air force base but
the point i'm trying to make is that
the air force base commander was well
aware of the of these black helicopters
and he had the wherewithal to be able to
track of where these helicopters were
coming from and he ran into a brick wall
i mean he simply could not have uh any
information on why these dozens and
dozens of black helicopters were showing
up around uh milestone air force base
usually in the aftermath of ufo
sightings and launching fighter aircraft
to intercept these ufo sightings so
that's it one example of what what i'm
talking about so we have these
um this ambiguity
regarding these helicopters
who owns them who was who was uh flying
them and why are they around i mean some
of them are obviously united states
military and some of them actually have
been tracked to various locations
um that that they are obviously us
military uh helicopters but others um
are just they kind of seem to disappear
into the into the woodwork and um there
is a big question mark about about their
origins so in answer to your question i
would say both
they're uh they're they're both united
states military and they're both
from somewhere else
is there any evidence that the cattle
mutilations are
because of the government that the
government instigates them in some way
well that's a long long story i i
i mean also did not do any
investigations of cattle mutilations
there were two
uh there were two aspects that we
decided
um and the defense intelligence agency
decided we would not spend a lot of time
and resources actually three of them uh
one was the remote viewing that i've
already discussed the second was the
calamus mutilation phenomenon and the
third one was we we decided not to
recruit a whole team to investigate
a ufo of quote-unquote abductions
because again that required an enormous
amount of uh resources that i know that
we knew at the time were not going to be
available so cattle mutilations were not
investigated by the uh the asap program
but um back in the national institute
for discovery science era uh we actually
did a lot of forensic investigations
of cattle mutilations and again i refer
to the ned's website which you can find
uh by googling national institute for
discovery science uh on wikipedia
and there are dozens of reports
of ned's investigations of calculations
on i will cut to the chase basically and
say that um
we
literally investigated dozens of
mutilations how do we investigate these
we actually had full-time veterinarian
on our staff
that veterinarian who was also a phd in
pathology so who was well used to doing
necropsies uh you know animal autopsies
and so
our our sort of bottom line was that
cattle mutilations
there was a body of evidence that was
lying on the ground and if we could get
to that that body quick enough after
death that we might be able to get some
answers so we evolved over many years a
situation where we had a bunch of
veterinarians who were accredited
veterinarians on call we had a bunch of
police
officers throughout the western states
in the united states also on call so we
were able to get um reports of
calculations
extremely quickly and the third thing
that we had was that we had a menu of
laboratory
uh analytical laboratories at our on
call on speed dial so that if we did
manage to get samples
we were able to do histopathology
analysis we were able to do chemical
analysis biochemical analysis and you
know uh pretty well all of the different
analytical frameworks so
we were pretty well equipped at the end
of ned's to be able to investigate
cattle mutilations and what we found was
that there was a really two two two
types of mutilations
once one was the standard sort of
mutilation where the uh the eye the ear
uh the uh sex organs uh were were
removed from the animal
and you know during that situat that
that uh
program for for nis
we did a lot of analytical chemistry we
did uh elemental analysis of the blood
from mutilated animals occasionally we
found what looked like sedatives we used
gas chromatography mass spectrometry we
used liquid chromatography mass
spectrometry we used inductive coupled
plasma mass spectrometry determine
elemental analysis so we threw the
kitchen sink in terms of analytical
capability at what was in these animals
following necropsy we also did histology
analysis and we determined that yes
sharp instruments were used but some of
the time we used uh we were able to
document
um
compounds like oxidol
succinal choline which are sedatives
so that made us suspicious on on other
occasions including investigations up in
montana uh we were able to locate
um you know 10 gauge needles that were
found under uh the
some of these animals in other cases we
were able to find medical paraphernalia
associated with exsanguinating an animal
in other words hooking up an animal to a
large gauge needle and removing all the
blood from the animal so
we began to get suspicious as time went
on that there was a pattern associated
with some of these cases so we we put
out the hypothesis
that you know maybe this was part of a a
case of um you know applying sedatives
to the animals um and then investigating
these animals for the spread of say an
infectious disease organism and you know
a lot of these infectious disease could
be um through the western herds in the
united states uh we
we investigated or we put out the
hypothesis that maybe
um some of these infectious proteins
called prions
might have been the source of concern
as they were sort of exploding in the
united kingdom and europe in the 1990s
and killing a lot of people who were
eating contaminated meat so there might
have been a small
very very small program all you need is
a couple of trained veterinarians a
couple of skill surgeons um a couple of
helicopters uh very small program in
other words that could monitor um the
spread of an infectious organism
through the cattle
in the wild in the western part of the
united states
why would you want to do that
rather than going to
say slaughterhouses and abattoirs and
sampling from there
the answer to that is you would not get
the same amount of data from sampling
avatars and slaughterhouses as you would
by
flying in at night and you know
basically sampling animals within you
know several hundred miles uh if you
were trying to track the spread of an
infectious organism prion is what one
can one uh
one an infectious protein that was
responsible for
you know
destruction of millions of animals in
the united kingdom and europe and it was
a source of huge amounts of concern in
the uh in in the united states in the
1990s as especially the
um you know the uh fda on the the usda
uh the the
united states department of agriculture
we're very concerned about the the
spread of this so
that was one hypothesis we came up with
why do we come up with this because we
use forensic analysis to determine that
somebody was using sharp instruments on
these animals to cut them open
we found that unequivocally from the
histopathology analysis and then we
found all of these suspicious compounds
through
standard forensic analytical uh
chemistry and and we also found evidence
of medical hardware
underneath an unassociated with a small
number of these animals so
um
you know that we put out this hypothesis
and again it's these published papers
are on the news website if people want
to take a look at them
let me add this kurt uh please to boil
that down so columns hypothesis was
there are two levels of mutilators
mystery mutilators there's the original
one that's been carrying this out for
decades under the cover of night carving
up animals with surgical precision
removing the same sort of parts
not leaving behind certain compounds not
leaving behind medical instruments it's
a complete mystery how it's carried out
there were some cases where high heat
instrumentation was used in these cases
the classic mutilation stories that
we've always heard nids investigated
those and and most of the cases they
investigated did not show these kind of
tell-tale signs of human intervention
someone mystery mutilators have been
carrying this out for decades over a
broad uh part of the united states
and and other parts of the world and
then later there were an additional
level of mutilators who came in under
the umbrella of this seemingly
paranormal mystery who operated with
impunity thinking they can get away with
it no one's really going to seriously
investigate it because it's the space
people doing these mysterious
mutilations there were cases on the
ranch for example that defy explanation
i'm thinking of one in particular
there were something like 14 head of
cattle that vanished that you'd see the
tracks lead out into the snow and then
the cow is gone as if it's sucked up
into the sky there were cases that the
neighbors reported of cattle that seemed
to have been dropped from the sky their
legs were broken
there were cases on the ranch one in
particular that we wrote about in a in
the hunt for the skinwalker the rancher
and his wife had had all this bizarre
activity on their property they carry on
uh they they were really financially
strapped because of the loss of these
very expensive animals
it's a sunday morning it's a bright
sunny day quiet out there in the country
they go out to tag the ears of newborn
calves they had several calves on the on
their pasture
they're going to tag the ears which is a
process that the ranchers do to identify
these animals there's a calf and it's
mom 50 yards from the house where they
live that's the first one they come to
they tag the ear this newborn calf they
move off across the property again very
quiet there's no obstruction the weather
is calm they go off on the property
about 30 minutes or so later a dog
that's traveling with them alerts them
that something's going on so they look
back at this calf the first one that
they had uh tagged and the mom the cow
is
going around in circles it's eyes are
bulging out it's obviously distressed
it's dragging its leg behind it
rancher and his wife go back over there
to where this this calf was this calf is
completely emaciated it is wiped out it
is stripped of all its flesh the only
thing left is bones and high there's no
blood in the animal there's no blood on
the ground 75 pounds of meat gone how
did it happen
why didn't they why weren't they able to
hear it could a predator what what
predator comes in and
wipes out a calf
and makes no sound and leaves no blood
nid's team brought in a tracker
professional tracker to look for animal
tracks
to look for human tracks vehicle tracks
didn't find him they took samples of
that set it to two different pathology
labs the uh the
investigators figured out that two
different cutting instruments had been
used something like a heavy machete to
whack off chunks of flesh and then
something with the scalpel type
precision
how does that happen how does it happen
in broad daylight that nobody sees it
now is that the mystery government
mutilators a team of commandos comes in
completely undetected and wipes out this
cap and leaves it there for people to
find um or is it something else i i
think it's probably something else maybe
colin wants to add to that
well
you know that it goes back to um
the idea that
it's very very easy for a team of people
who are
sampling carrying out these illegal
killings of cattle
sampling at night because you've got two
things that are working for you and that
is
number one
you've got this whole aura of ufos
associated with cattle mutilations and
no respectable veterinarian or no
respectable police officer wants to have
anything to do with this if there's even
the taint of quote-unquote aliens
associated uh with it and the second
thing that you have going for you is you
have the decomposition process
especially in summer i mean the
decomposition process of a
cow is extremely rapid because their
entire uh rumen which is the second or
third stomach that they have is loaded
with bacteria and microorganisms which
actually chew up
the entire flesh extremely quickly so
all you have to do if you are actually
sampling an animal on the ground is wait
for 48 hours and pretty well all of the
evidence is gone by means of mother
nature you don't even have to cover up
your tracks all you have to do is is
take your samples and and get out of
there but you know what george is saying
is absolutely true there were a small
number of these cases that were
where we documented and they were
obviously
not the uh you know the perpetrators
that i've been talking about there was
something else going on um and we we
documented cases in northern california
that were they also had this weird um
effect that that george described of the
case on in utah
we documented other cases in california
too so there was a small component of
these that had this
um bizarre
paranormal taint
to it and then you had this other
large number of cases
that were consistent with some kind of a
sampling exercise and you know it's the
same kind of thing as the ufo phenomenon
uh the united states government used the
ufo phenomenon as a way of covering up
their
their special access programs so maybe
some sort of small contractor was using
the ufo lord associated with with cat
mutilations to also cover up their
tracks
you know same kind of thing there are
levels of deception
involved in investigating these kinds of
anomalies
george and colin i know you both have to
go so how about i read two questions and
you can choose one of them so this one
comes from stephen greenstreet and he
wants to know
what is the best piece of evidence of
something paranormal occurring at
skinwalker ranch and i'll add an
addendum best public piece of evidence
okay then
the second question is chris one two
three four five six seven eight nine it
says
and this is a wonderful question okay
if there were no observer to witness
these uaps bigfoot cattle mutilations
dark shadow etc would they still happen
how much of these phenomena are perhaps
co-created by a consciousness observing
them are these phenomena independent
entities with lives history goals
instincts of their own or are they
manifestations
for the benefit of a conscious observer
in our case a human being
i think you should take that one column
well i mean you have brought up the sort
of or your listener that's a very sort
of
loaded question um because it does
it does get into this whole um
sort of dichotomy between
uh observer versus observed it gets into
sort of the the quantum
these quantum realities of how
whether or not observers interfere with
uh with
uh with experiments at the at the
quantum level and also it does sort of
raise the question of uh what exactly is
human consciousness and
you know what one of one of what
that the aspects that has been really
intriguing me is in the last five to ten
years there really has been a sort of a
literal explosion
of uh new people who are entering the
field
of uh you know the investigation of
human consciousness
and and they're you know some of these
people are sort of taking a stance on
human consciousness that is away from
the standard dogma that we've had for
about 100 years which is that
consciousness arises as a result of
neurochemical trafficking in the brain
and some of these people like you know i
i can think of bernardo castro in the
netherlands and donald hoffman who is a
pre professor at uc irvine um federico
faheen who is literally the in the
inventor of the microprocessor
at intel corporation i mean talk about
hard-nosed materialist but i mean he's
written a book or our two books i think
recently
that are basically saying that
consciousness may not arise as a as a
result of neurochemical trafficking in
the brain we've got people like edward
professor edward kelly at the division
of perceptual studies at the university
of virginia um you know and even in the
biological arena you've got
professor
robert lanza who's written a couple of
books on on biocentrism
i mean these people are also all saying
the same thing that you know
consciousness is prime you know
consciousness is really the sort of the
mover and the shaker in this whole
equation so
you know bernardo castro especially has
sort of uh written in some of the blogs
that he's written for scientific
american and uh elsewhere he's really
reduced it down to
uh sort of concepts that
you know even a biologist like myself
can understand and that is you know he's
he's put out this concept you know of of
you know maybe
maybe our our
sense of reality is is actually
look more like the dashboard of an
aircraft and that you're flying an
aircraft via instruments and outside
this aircraft um there's a sort of a
storm and there's a whole lot of
different things happening
but the pilot of the aircraft is flying
purely by use of this instrumentation
and so you know human that the
translation of the metaphor into human
consciousness is that human perception
is a function of the dashboard and our
five senses are are essentially the
instrumentation that we're flying with
through life and outside these five
senses there's a whole world that we are
not perceiving and so one hypothesis of
the intersection of ufos versus this
sort of avant-garde way of looking at
human consciousness is that maybe ufos
are outside the dashboard um and they
they seem to appear or disappear at sort
of a out of whim or sort of in a very
sort of fast way
maybe they're outside this sort of
dashboard and that you know
people in the future as they
attack the ufo phenomenon
we need sort of people who are um part
of this vanguard of human consciousness
research because there may be overlaps
that we just have not looked at and you
know the sort of
the standard way of looking at the ufo
phenomenon especially sort of
um from the perspective of the military
intelligence apparatus is we are going
to study only um
the ufo performance we're going to study
only the five observables uh or the six
observables the the parameters of a ufo
that make it extremely
um unlikely that it is you know a
special access program from the united
states um and that's all we're going to
do everything else is off the table
because quote unquote it's not a part of
the mandate from the united states
security apparatus but guess what you
know maybe the ufo phenomenon doesn't
care at all about the
security parameters of the united states
on what constitutes security parameters
and what constitutes a viable way of
investigating this phenomenon maybe the
united states military is going to
investigate using this narrow
perspective and completely miss the boat
i mean we've seen and heard snippets and
rumors and innuendo that some of these
tic-tac-tac pilots had long-term uh
effects you know that might even include
long-term effects on their psychology
and maybe their health or maybe their
consciousness so i see going forward
that you know we really need to broaden
the scope of the ufo investigative
framework as opposed to
narrowing it and i don't care what a
bureaucrat from under secretary of
defense for intelligence decides to say
what is part of the united states uh
military
uh perspective or not i don't think the
ufo
phenomenon really cares
as for the question from stephen about
the best evidence regarding the ranch of
paranormal events
i'd answered this way i mean you know
robert bigelow in an interview we did
uh years ago and then another one last
year you know it's maddening what
happens at the ranch it's frustrating in
that whatever the intelligence is that's
there it calls the shots we get to see
what it allows us to see the most
compelling accounts come from
eyewitnesses the people who've been on
the property you know bigelow bought the
ranch in the mid 90s there's been a
constant presence there since the nid
study the aw sap study and then the
current efforts by brandon fugle and all
three of those groups have experienced
the same kinds of things it's never
exactly the same
the only thing that's predictable is its
unpredictability
a lot of the the accounts the very
compelling stories are things that
people see once and then it's gone
this intelligence and i think it is an
intelligence plays games it's a
trickster it messes with your mind it
always seems to know what you are going
to do before you do it
so
dramatic incidents can happen and
there's nothing left behind
to prove that it ever happened but
occasionally it becomes it has a
physical effect it has physical
demonstrable measurable effects for
example what happens to the animals you
have cattle that are mutilated you have
cats that are carved up in the middle of
the night in a snowstorm dogs that are
incinerated horses that are slashed by
these crypto creatures those things
happen they were documented uh you have
physical effects for example there were
four large bulls during the nids era
that were in this corral the rancher and
his wife are going to town they've
already lost a lot of different uh heads
of livestock they're in danger of going
under financially they say to each other
casually boy if something happens to one
of those bulls we're in big trouble they
come back and less than an hour later
all four of the bulls are gone in a
panic they go looking for them
somehow those four bulls had been in
essence dematerialized from the corral
and crammed into this tiny storage shed
adjacent to this corral they're in a in
there the rancher finds them they're
kind of in a trance crammed in there you
could not get these these bulls into
there with a forklift and a team of army
commandos but somehow they got in there
they let the bulls out the bulls kick
off the side of it they get out they're
very surly in a bad mood photos are
taken the subsequent physical effects
that were measured by the nids guys
where the entire metal corral had been
magnetized and it stayed magnetized for
a couple of days there are all these
measurable em effects and effects on
equipment for example all three of those
organizations
have put all kinds of cameras out there
camera gear both up on on on poles and
at different places of the ranch and
they carry uh gear compasses and other
sensors to try to document effects this
phenomena whatever it is laughs at it it
will knock out compasses compasses will
spin around uh they're they're of no use
you have a camera the batteries drain
the camera dies right before something
happens where the camera would have been
able to document it it's infuriating
it's frustrating to try to document
things but it happens over and over
again over a period of almost close to
30 years now um so there are measurable
effects there was an ice circle that we
documented during the the mids period
that the nids guys documented an
impossible thing that was carved in this
tiny little thin layer of ice
they can't figure out how it happened
there was a there was one instance where
something went up a 75-foot telephone
pole where they had a camera and
destroyed it destroyed it while another
camera was watching it whatever did it
was invisible it's very frustrating i
think it's frustrating on purpose it
gives us glimpses
of this other reality at times there
were holes in the sky that would appear
and craft would come in and out there
were craft that seemed to fly directly
into skinwalker ridge uh that defy our
physics uh there were other craft that
were you know the rancher in the family
they're in the first years that they
were there they'd see these things
they're not trying to document it for a
ufo audience they're trying to survive
out there on what they thought was their
dream property they end up giving it up
and moving away because they were so
frustrated by what happened to them so
it is difficult to document it is a
challenge to document it but it's a it's
an intriguing challenge it's an exciting
challenge and it's one we have to take
on there is physical evidence that can
be examined and investigated a lot of
the things that happen are not in the
physical realm that makes it more of a
challenge i would think
thank you so much george thank you so
much colin i appreciate it there are
more than 3 000 people watching
so
say hello to them
many of them are just expressing their
thanks and plaudits toward you all so
thank you so much
it's
it's a pleasure it's it's been it's a
it's a blessing thank you
thanks kurt talk to you again it's been
really good to have this discussion
enjoyable
okay and like i mentioned we'll look
into a part two in a few months so if
anyone has lingering questions just
write them down
take care i'll stick around to speak
with the audience if i can
thanks
bye bye
okay
okay
yeah no it's not a sickness like that
what i'm feeling it's it's something
else it's not it's not a virus it's
nothing like that it's more
yeah
i can't talk about it
okay so let's see
wolfstein thank you
jacob asks what work can individuals do
to contribute to the study of this i
believe somewhere around 35 minutes into
this maybe 40 minutes into this
column outlined some of that
so i'll go and look into that
and i will try to timestamp that
oral decoy says vertigo and anxiety i
can relate yeah i would say that it's
not vertical but anxiety wilheim
says linda moulton deserves and
apologize so i know what you may mean an
apology and i
i don't want to talk about this publicly
because it doesn't
it's not
it's like praying in public it's not
something that should be done but i did
apologize to
linda
thank you thank you everyone for
your
your kind comments a couple people were
mentioned
bernardo castro was mentioned
donald hoffman was mentioned just so you
know there's an interview with bernardo
castro i'm going to link that it's going
to be in the description same with
donald hoffman on this channel i think
they're some of the best with them and
that's not because of
myself it's because i happen to catch
them at great days
um
on their best behavior
and
donald hoffman is also coming on live on
sunday with yoshibok to talk about
consciousness after salvatore pais and
gary nolan which will occur in a few
weeks or so i'm thinking of taking a
lengthy break from this ufo content
the i tend to take matters
on this channel extremely seriously
whether they're about consciousness
theories or physics or what have you and
it's extremely destabilizing to me i
perhaps i shouldn't be taking them as
seriously as i do but i but i
but i
i treat them
while i take them seriously
and there's this quote by rene descartes
which says which says something like i
heard you say something like i've fallen
unexpectedly into a deep whirlpool and i
can't stand at the bottom nor swim to
the top
so that's much like how i feel
and i want to also make sure that what
i'm doing on this ufo topic is fresh
and salutary
and while the comment section is filled
with plaudits
i want to make sure that the adulation
or the approbation is directed toward
the toe approach or the questions asked
i want to make sure that
that i'm
well i don't i don't see it i i it
doesn't mean it's not there it's just
that i don't see it so i need to be able
to see it and i also want to make sure
that i'm
there's so much that i want to make sure
that this is it's obvious that these
videos are quite popular on the toe
channel they're the most popular
and i i fear
i want to make sure that what i'm doing
i'm not doing i'm not pursuing because
it's favored and it's so
like i don't feel like i am i feel like
i'm genuine about it and and i'm earnest
but i know how easy it is to delude
oneself into pursuing what's popular
so i need to take some time and collect
myself i've seen people like even
even jordan peterson go down that route
where he has great work in psychology
and religion and now almost all of his
content is about
being anti-woken so on
and i i don't
i feel like he became embittered from
that and followed some of the crowd i
need to make sure that i'm not doing
that i need to make sure that what i'm
doing is not selfish
and not
filled with
perfidy
mendacity
lies and deceit
not that it is not that it is but i'm
saying that
i need to introspect some more but i
also do too much introspection i'm a bit
extreme on that there is an upside to it
though that it would give some of the uf
let's think of the toe
project as being split into two audience
the ufo audience and then those who are
more interested in the stem fields while
it may be true that those who are in the
stem fields like the theoretical math
and physics should be more interested in
the phenomenon and that learning a
little bit about it can aid their
understanding of stem while that's true
i think the flip side is also true where
understanding even a modicum of the
foundations of mathematics and physics
may aid one's understanding of the
phenomenon so perhaps it will give some
of the people who are on the more ufo
oriented end of the toe audience or the
toe projects audience
a chance to go through some of the other
podcasts on this channel
in fact there's a starter playlist that
i've put together
sorted in terms of what's most
entertaining slash informative slash
easy to go through i'll put a link to
that in the description
jasmine says are you going to address
how ridiculously ridiculously ignorant
and disrespectful your chat is always
when these topics are being discussed
well i wouldn't say my chat that's such
a it's so tricky the the chat that
happens on the videos that
are posted on this channel yeah well i
don't know i don't have time to look
through these when i'm speaking and i do
with regard to linda molten howe i do
condemn the comments that speak ill of
her especially with derision i don't
think that one should be derogatory
toward linda or any guest you can be
derogatory toward me the toe project is
about love it's about clemency so please
if you're being snide
and you're desprising then that's not
the compassionate understanding that the
toe project is trying to emulate
so i'll say that
no also keep in mind keep in mind hey
for something
this fractious
this controversial this topic that's so
alarming
the
comments are actually extremely civil
so that i'm surprised about while
obviously there are
there are negative comments i'm almost
always surprised at how much positive
comments there are there's so much that
i want to say about that linda molten
howe interview there's so much that i
regret and so much that i i just but i
feel like what i would be doing would be
justifying myself like a little child
and i don't want to do that i just want
to take my lumps
though there's so much that is false
that i've read for example
linda was under the impression that i
didn't read
or go through the material that she sent
which is false i watched all of what she
sent as for reading well she has plenty
of work and there were tomes so i wasn't
able to read all of it though i skimmed
it
and i feel like that contributed to a
negative impression of her toward me i
feel like my questions were ill-timed i
feel like it's false to say that i was
harder on her than i was on other guests
and someone keeps saying yeah but your
average guess what do you mean average
but in statistics you don't look at the
average you look at variance like you
have to look there's something they're
higher order corrective terms variance
is one of them because if it unless a
distribution is simple then average
means nothing and i would say was in the
variance of the channel the way that i
spoke with her it doesn't mean that i
spoke optimally but i would i wouldn't
say it was drastically different
and i do regret it i do regret how it
happened some people say yeah you didn't
push back enough or you pushed back too
much my role on this toe
channel is not to be a skeptic or to
push back
that's not how i see it i i don't think
in terms of that i don't even think in
terms of well how many i have to have
one hard question per
every five questions
i just wanted to know if
she was aware of the criticisms of her
work which is why i kept bringing it up
i didn't hear the answers from her
so i would repeat questions and thus we
spent more time on the criticisms
quote-unquote criticisms because i had
to keep repeating the questions because
she would give
an answer that was five to ten minutes
long and i couldn't hear the response to
my inquiry in there
now there's someone like lu elisando
who's infamous for not answering the
question so why is it any different with
him well the difference with lou is that
lou
lou is self-aware that he's not
answering the questions directly and
we'll even bring it up like he'll either
say i can't answer it because of reasons
x y and z
or he'll
parenthetically give an answer so i'll
give an answer that's parenthetically
related or metaphorically related or
thematically related and also there were
shorter answers
whereas with linda i would wait i'm
listening i'm listening i'm like linda i
didn't quite hear the answer to that
and also as for
speaking with her for two and a half
hours the interview was essentially of
unlim of unspecified time
and she had just come from proudly
stating that she has more energy than
she's ever had and that she works
18-hour days and that she speaks at
conferences for hours on end so i didn't
think it was uncouth to ask her hey can
you answer a couple more questions i
know we've been going for two and a half
hours
in fact i was taking her at her word
when she said that she had more energy
than she's ever had either way i just
have to move forward from that
okay well everyone
thank you
take care everyone i appreciate you all
being here
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l
that is kurt jaimungle it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full-time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you